if kyp loiter at the entrance some
people decide against buying an SUV
explains our car reviewer Klaus many
find them too big and too thirsty this
is the alternative a station wagon as
offered by many manufacturers these days
VW has the Passat Alltrack Volvo the
cross-country and Audi also has
four-wheel drive wagons combi simple
come then my body most people looking
for a wagon wouldn't necessarily think
of a Subaru Outback observes Klaus but
it's a pretty interesting car and has
been on the market for some time now
this car has been completely revamped
there's a new front section and a new
interior now Klaus is going to show us
what else the Outback has to offer we
plumped for a diesel model for our test
drive but there's also a 3.6 liter
gasoline engine available with 260
horsepower and a 2.5 liter gasoline unit
with 173 horsepower does out pectus
outback is a bit of a flagship for
subaru says Klaus although in Germany
it's far from being among the best known
wagons this new edition is supposed to
change that veneto Burlington close
isn't a huge fan of CVT transmissions
based on past experience but this is a
slightly different scenario it has seven
gears that can be selected manually the
minor drawback is that fuel consumption
is 0.3 or point four litres more than a
manual shift
in other words the diesel-powered subaru
officially needs around 5.9 liters for
100 kilometers and with a CVT gearbox
6.3 leaders the permanent symmetrical
all-wheel drive comes in handy here over
easy going to rain the outback copes
masterfully with most challenges and
also has very interesting towing
abilities you can also change gears via
these shift paddles what's up with Klaus
is also impressed by the boxer engine
and delivers 340 newton meters of torque
which is great for cruising and in the
lower revs range too there's always
plenty of power available the engine
noise development on the inside is
absolutely ok
station wagons are very popular in
Germany but Subaru is also looking for
customers in other markets market our
real interest is Northern Europe says
Subaru Germany chief folk are donít the
man for wagons is especially high there
in Germany the proportion of wagons
compared to a comparable sedan is over
seventy percent so Subaru is an
excellent company here and the Outback
is also impressive on the design front
both the interior and exterior exude
good taste and quality materials
high-quality leather seats and an
attractive color scheme complete the
package the cargo capacity is also
considerable you can pack in up to 1,700
25 litres at the back dacia if this is
one horsepower which is enough for some
people here we have 150 horsepower
generated by a 2-liter diesel engine
what makes the Subaru special for Klaus
is the boxer engine the low position of
the engine gives the car a relatively
low center of gravity an elective teeth
and shrivelled that gives the outback a
top speed of 195 kilometers an hour and
a time of nine point seven seconds for
the dash to 100 the future looks bright
for the outback not least because its
standard equipment is far more extensive
than that of its rivals
the Subaru is a sound off-roader and on
regular roads too it has a well-balanced
ride in handling
so no guns the basic outback cost thirty
seven thousand euros overall Klaus
reckons this is a car with ample
interior space and efficient engine and
then the best news of all it comes with
a five-year warranty not bad at all does
he i'm honestly the new Subaru Outback
has been on the market since May